[Music]
thousands gather to call for illegal
Israeli settlements to be rebuilt in
Gaza and for Palestinians to be expelled
from their homes among them cabinet
ministers and Coalition lawmakers
including the country's national
security minister and alter nationalist
itamar benir who called for settlements
not just to be rebuilt in Gaza but also
in the northern occupied West Bank
Mr Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu I'm
addressing you from this stage it's a
shame to wait another another 19 years
to understand that gush and Northern
Samaria must be returned the
responsibility of Brave leadership is to
make courageous
decisions Netanyahu says he does not
intend to maintain a permanent presence
in Gaza again but that Israel would
maintain security control for some time
but some of those in his cabinet want
more we are settling our land from width
to length controlling it and fighting
Terror always and bringing with God's
help security to all of Israel you know
what the answer is without settlement
there is no security once seen as Fringe
voices they are now at the heart of
Israel's government opposition leader
yair Leed posting this scathing
statement on social media the settlement
conference on Gaza by the Otay yudit
party with many ministers from the
liquid party is a disgrace to Netanyahu
and to a party that was once at the
center of the national camp and is now
trailing helplessly behind the
extremists Palestinians say there is
real danger in meetings like this one in
this conference 12 Israeli ministers
participated including ministers from
The leud Party The Party of Mr Netanyahu
additionally 15 members of of the
Israeli KET participated so it's not a
joke these are these are the people who
are making the policy in Israel and they
were calling for ethnic cleansing of
Gaza complete ethnic cleansing of the
people of Gaza Israel withdrew from Gaza
after a 38-year occupation in 2005 this
included the evacuation of 21 illegal
settlements if new settlements were
built it would be against international
law and the public position of Israel's
biggest Ally the United States ham Al
jaaz occupied East
Jerusalem make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer